Émilie Nicolas est avec nous à les
castonguette avec nous pour notre panel
politique et on attend et c'est quand
même ironique on est chez lui à Québec
Jonathan a eu un pépin d'ordi
d'ordinateur il va être avec nous dans
quelques secondes
je commence avec vous Émilie
la campagne à chèvre là on va se
retourner puis wouh c'est terminé les
choses semblent pas avoir bougé beaucoup
les questions qui demeurent c'est des
questions régionales il y a des
circonscriptions très intéressantes
est-ce que pour vous c'est réglé ou il
faut faire attention il reste quand même
plusieurs jours
c'est sûr qu'il reste plusieurs jours
puis qui on peut se jamais savoir ce qui
peut arriver au niveau national au
niveau des communications des différents
partis on n'est jamais à l'abri d'une
surprise ceci dit il y a beaucoup de
secret qui sont très serrées on parle
d'une course à 5 au Québec sauf que le
circonscription ça conscription il y a à
peu près jamais plus que deux joueurs
des fois deux trois conceptions il y a
trois jours principaux donc à Chauveau
par exemple à Québec puis dans Jean
Lesage personnellement c'est les deux
circonscriptions que je surveiller dans
la région où c'est ça vaut vraiment
probablement se jouer de pourcentage en
pourcentage en fonction des des boîtes
de vote de scrutin qu'on va ouvrir ça
risque d'être resserré durant la soirée
électorale à moins que quelque chose
change bien
lundi prochain
tous les regards vont se tourner vers
Chauveau au début de la soirée voir
est-ce que le Parti conservateur est
compétitif peut-il
parler derrière moi au Parlement ou pas
là
c'est important pour Éric duem parce que
va-t-il y avoir pour lui une conjoncture
aussi favorable dans quatre ans s'il ne
fait pas dès maintenant son entrée à
l'Assemblée nationale où vont en être la
grogne envers les mesures sanitaires
dans 4 ans sur laquelle le Parti
conservateur a construit
sa montée pas certains que ça va être
encore à l'ordre du jour donc il a
besoin de cette tribune là irides amis
le besoin d'entrer l'Assemblée nationale
idéalement lui bon s'il peut en faire
élire deux ou trois autres il sera bien
content mais idéalement qu'il y a au
moins un représentant on va voir accès à
l'Assemblée nationale au point de presse
participo commission parlementaires à
être visible pendant les prochaines
années pour continuer à construire son
mouvement si les choux qu'il n'y a aucun
député et que lui-même n'est pas élu ça
va être plus compliqué d'en 4 ans alors
certainement que lui va essayer de
profiter du de l'élan là créé par la
grogne autour de la pandémie Jonathan
bonsoir à vous donc je demandais à
quelques jours une semaine en fait du
vote on se demandait est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est déjà plié emballé ou
les choses peuvent bouger encore il y a
beaucoup d'intérêts on vient d'en parler
est-ce que
Eric Djem va oui ou non être capable de
faire élire un député qu'est-ce que vous
surveillez cette semaine
les régions de Québec je pense qu'on va
surveiller ça de très très près bref
échéance il y avait le vote par
anticipation on se rend compte que dans
la capitale nationale ça a voté très
très fort mais c'est difficile de
décoder ce que ça veut dire est-ce que
c'est une indication que les militants
qui appuient
massivement pour aller appuyer leurs
candidat un peu comme on a vu les
candidats depuis un polyèvre le faire
parce qu'il y a des similitudes entre
ces deux mouvements là à savoir un quand
même un grand succès de mobilisation
mais on se demandait avec Pierre Pellier
est-ce que les gens vont se déplacer
pour aller voter ils l'ont fait que le
vote postal donc on peut présumer que
c'est la même chose pour Éric Zem par
contre je vérifié avant d'aller en
annonce avec des organisateurs kakis et
eux aussi ils sont radieux qu'une
machine très très bien huilée sont
confiants qu'ils ont réussi à faire
sortir le vote au cours au cours des 24
24 36 dernières heures Patrice ça va
être très très intéressant parce que il
y a pas si longtemps que ça encore moi
je voyais encore je vous voyez qu'il
existait encore un scénario dans lequel
Eric Djem ne parvenait pas à faire élire
de députés dans la capitale nationale
oui les phares mais la CAPAC elle est
très très forte et jouit de la faiblesse
des parties d'opposition or on voit que
le Parti québécois s'améliore et en même
temps ben on a un parti laquelle qui a
qu'à fouiller avec un dossier majeur
dans la région de Québec qui est celui
du troisième bien ce qui peut grurer un
peu son vote donc rien n'est perdu pour
irrégulier mais ce stade-ci est-ce que
on peut interpréter je vous pose à vous
trois la question
le fait que le vote par anticipation est
beaucoup plus fort des 10
circonscriptions championne au Québec
depuis hier matin il y en a 7 dans la
région de Québec qu'est-ce que ça vous
dit ça Alec
pas grand chose parce que ça fait
plusieurs élections que c'est la région
non mais ça fait plusieurs élections
consécutives que c'est la région de
Québec qui est en tête des du vote par
anticipation c'est la même chose en 2018
les mêmes circonscriptions Louis Hébert
Lévy donc
est-ce que est-ce que pourquoi on vote
plutôt à Québec je sais pas peut-être
qu'on est plus convaincu on a
l'impression que la dernière semaine
changera rien la machine de la CAQ est
beaucoup plus efficace qu'elle l'était
Jonathan a raison et on met sur le vote
par anticipation lorsqu'on est haut dans
les sondages en se disant ben pourquoi
prendre un risque d'attendre encore une
semaine allons-y tout de suite donc
est-ce que ça aide à faire sortir le
vote dans la région de Québec peut-être
mais en définitive c'est des
circonscriptions particulières parfois
les gens sont plus âgés vont voter par
anticipation ce qu'ils ont pas le goût
d'attendre d'être pris dans la file donc
moi je le décode pas grand chose la
région de Québec plutôt du vote par
anticipation vous êtes attention aux
analyses avant de là-dessus
je pense qu'on peut juste spéculer pour
essayer de comprendre pourquoi est-ce
que les gens ont tendance à voter plutôt
dans la région Québec mais façon
générale la seule chose qu'on peut dire
c'est que quand les gens votent les gens
votent tous c'est parce que ça sent
interpellés par la campagne je pense
qu'on a beaucoup parlé des enjeux
régionaux d'agents Québec durant cette
campagne-ci
probablement la campagne d'avant aussi
on a tendance à beaucoup parler on fait
de la région de Québec en campagne
électorale provinciale de manière
générale c'est sûr que ça peut avoir une
influence sur le fait que les lecteurs
moyen se sont se sont concernés par le
discours d'échec bon là on voit des
images de pont c'est inévitable même ça
gaz des gens on peut déjà nous disent
bon Dieu vous en parlez de ce dossier du
troisième lien est-ce qui a marqué des
points vous en avez un peu parlé
Jonathan qui a marqué des points selon
vous dans le dossier du troisième lien
dans la région de Québec tour de table
je commence avec vous Jonathan
probablement les conservateurs en fait
j'aurais peut-être eu envie de demander
qui en a le moins perdu je pense que
c'est la façon avec laquelle on peut on
peut l'analyser parce que laquelle ils
sont à me dire que bien bien des gens
dans la région au cours des dernières
semaines donc on a l'impression qu'il se
mette un peu tout le monde à dos
c'est-à-dire les gens qui sont contre le
projet 3e lien ils sont très très
présents ils se font entendre et l'autre
d'un autre côté ben avec un François
Legault qui a insisté en cours des
dernières semaines des derniers jours
pour nous dire à quel point il y avait
pas d'études pour le troisième à quel
point le projet qui a été présenté dans
le fond il est relativement embryonnaire
donc dans la région de Québec bien des
gens qui se sont dit ben ils ont fait
quoi finalement dans les dans les quatre
dernières années on nous avait promis
d'accélérer le projet donc les gens qui
sont choqués par contre le projet qui
régulait lui a présenté est absolument
loufoque je me plais à dire que si dans
la région de Québec Eric Djem a
longtemps dit que le projet de tramway
de registre la bombe avait été rédigé
sur une on dirait que le projet
troisième année dérive a été rédigé sur
un simple post-it tellement que c'est
embryonnaire tellement qu'on a
l'impression qu'il y ait pas vraiment de
sens donc il aurait pu je pense
davantage bénéficier de la faiblesse de
la CAQ sur le troisième lien mais en
même temps comme il est plus ou moins
crédible je je mesure mal à quel point
finalement la cacahua plus perdre des
habits là
insiste sur le manque de transparence de
la carte ou le côté broche à foin de la
carte sur le troisième lien ça le lui
permet peut-être d'avoir un discours qui
lui fait sortir de sa base idéologique
l'hypertarines conservatrice donc il
peut rejoindre un public un peu plus
large avec ça et puis c'est sûr que pour
les opposants au troisième lien et pour
les promoteurs aussi du tramway qui sont
très présents dans la région de Québec
aussi c'est sûr que je pense que c'est
Québec solidaire que le plus clair
là-dessus pour les électeurs
principalement dans tâches trop dans
j'en ai ça sur des espoirs d'avoir des
députés Québec solidaires donc vraiment
je pense que la CAF au niveau des
communications ça a été difficile je
sais pas si ça leur fait perdre des
compter à Québec mais peut-être que dans
d'autres régions du Québec il y a
peut-être qu'on en a parlé qu'on en a
pas parlé bien de ce projet-là peut-être
que ça peut venir à laquelle dans
certains dans certains contenus avec
je ne pense pas que c'est oui le
cafouillage autour du troisième lien de
la carte irréelle je ne pense pas que ça
va lui coûter des circonscriptions je
suis étonné que ce soit sur ce qu'on
veut puni qu'on veut punir François
Legault même s'il est très populaire le
troisième lien autant sur la réussite
que sur la Rive-Nord et on le voit dans
les sondages à Québec la plupart des
électeurs sont des conservateurs fiscaux
ce qui aime pas c'est le prix qui va
avec le troisième lien ça les dérange le
la première facture de 10 milliards de
dollars pour un tunnel ça fait dresser
les cheveux sur la tête de bien des gens
même s'il aime le troisième lit qui le
juge nécessaire alors là où est réduit
avec un je suis d'accord avec Jonathan
tout proche il y a pas beaucoup de
chance de voir le jour parce que l'île
de relein ils vont pas se laisser faire
aussi facilement il est moins cher il
est 3.5 milliards et ce qui continue
d'agacer bien des gens c'est la facture
d'un tunnel 6 7 milliards et c'est pas
pour rien que François Lego avait fait
baisser la facture de 10 à 6 ça va
réduire le projet c'est ça frapper
imaginaire 10 milliards donc c'est ça
qui est encore bien des gens qui ont
avec lesquels la difficulté donc sur
chaque avec quoi il devrait composer
François Legault à l'avenir bon
l'économie on le vu on l'entendu depuis
quelques jours monsieur Lego remet ça de
l'avant disant en période d'incertitude
regardez l'équipe que j'ai puis regarder
les équipes des autres c'est sans
conteste qu'on a on est on est favorisé
est-ce que ça alex je conseille vous
tour de table parce que ça c'est pas
peut-être qu'on revient au tout début de
cette campagne là ou c'est le thème
d'économie qui avait été mentionné en
premier et par monsieur Legault et par
Madame anglais est-ce que c'est pas là
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui sera l'enjeu
déterminant allez c'est un très bon
thème pour François Legault comme ça
avait été un très bon thème pour Jean
Cheret en 2008 pour Steven un peu aussi
lorsque des turbulences économiques à
l'horizon on a tendance à favoriser un
gouvernement qu'on connaît une équipe
qu'on connaît que prouver dans le passé
qui était capable de tenir la barre si
j'étais François Legault je ferai une
bonne partie de la dernière semaine de
campagne autour de mon équipe économique
dire voyez les marchés financiers voyez
les nuages à l'horizon vous voyez les
taux d'intérêt qui augmentent ça vous
prend une équipe qui a prouvé qu'il est
capable de naviguer lorsque ça va pas
très bien moi je jouerai cette carte là
à fond si j'étais lui parce que ça
prouvé pour toutes sortes de partie dans
le passé que ça fonctionne plutôt bien
on reprend la boutade américaine et deal
que les gens cherchez pas à mille en jeu
c'est l'enjeu qui fait déplacer des gens
pour aller au vote Jonathan
le concept de questions de l'urne me
fait toujours un peu sourire parce qu'il
faut bien dire aux gens qu'il y a pas de
grandes réunions ou finalement toutes
les citoyens tous les citoyens
québécoises
c'est appartient à tout un chacun mais
ce qui peut se dégager de façon générale
c'est qu'il y a bien des gens qui
effectivement auront comme priorité
l'économie mais quand on regarde les
différents programmes je pense pas que
ce qui permet François Legault de se
débarquer s'étend ce qu'il met de
l'avant par rapport aux autres parties
mais c'est plutôt de se dire est-ce que
les gens disent que dans le fond le
gouvernement qui est là on peut lui
donner une deuxième chance ou lui donner
la chance de continuer si on veut son
son
œuvre en disant que bah les finalement
les autres parties d'opposition ne se
sont pas particulièrement débarqués par
leurs idées ont pas réussi à proposer
des choses qui font en sorte qu'il
s'impose comme une meilleure alternative
va prendre soin le goût donc en ce sens
que oui c'est un bon un bon clou sur
lequel sur lequel frapper pour François
lingot d'ici la fin de la campagne ouais
on l'a vu Émilie là il en reparle quoi
depuis au milieu de la semaine dernière
puis au débat absolument absolument
fait de l'économie son enjeu à lui la
personne qui se fait plus mal c'est
devenu candidable et les libéraux qui
ont beaucoup discuté à ce défi dans
cette campagne-ci si la carte soit
capable de l'économie c'est difficile de
savoir ce que le parti miracare étant
donné que c'est ça que ce soit accaparis
historiquement après c'est sûr que il y
a d'autres parties qui essaient de
pousser une autre question de mur je
voyais au niveau des des communications
de Québec solidaire c'est sûr que en
plus avec la marche pour le climat qui a
eu en fin de semaine c'est vraiment il
essaie vraiment poussé pour
l'environnement puisque la voie des
jeunes et je pense que pour le Parti
québécois on essaie plutôt de dire
que en fait le Parti québécois mérite de
rester de mérite de continuer à exister
et c'est pour donc les gens qui
voudraient voter avec un autre un autre
peut-être un jeu que de dire moi chez
l'économie c'est l'environnement c'est
un enjeu précis mais plutôt voté en
fonction de quelle partie on va être
présente voir représenter à l'Assemblée
nationale parce que pour le Parti
conservateur ça semble vraiment à être
un discours où on essaie de mettre les
quatre autres parties dans le même
panier en disant nous on est les seuls
qui sont différents donc si vous voulez
du changement on est les seuls à
vraiment vous le ferez
en tout cas on en parlera dans les
prochains jours
dépendant des résultats la réforme
éventuelle du mode de scrutin même si
monsieur Legault a dit on se bat pas
dans les autobus puis personne veut ça
sauf quelques intellectuels cette
question là va peut-être être mise sur
le tapis on verra ok merci beaucoup à
vous trois très gentils à très bientôt
au revoir bonne soirée au revoir